PROTESTERS.
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL SHOWS US WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND WHO IS BEING
BLAMED.
>> RECENT PROTESTS INSIDE IRAN
HAVE BEEN DEADLY WITH SECURITY
FORCES TURNING THEIR WEAPONS ON
THEIR OWN PEOPLE.
AND THREATENING TO RESOLUTELY
CONFRONT GROWING UNREST OVER
ECONOMIC STRUGGLES.
THE REGIME HAS ALSO LASHED OUT
AT THE U.S. AND ISRAEL ACCUSING
THEM OF TRYING TO TRICK
PROTESTERS.
TODAY THE ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
SPOKE DIRECTLY TO THE IRANIAN
PEOPLE ON TWITTER.
>> THE IRANIAN PEOPLE ARE
BRILLIANT.
THEY ARE INNOVATIVE.
SO WHY IS IRAN SO POOR.
WHY IS UNEMPLOYMENT SO RAMPANT?
THE ANSWER IS IN TWO WORDS "THE
REGIME."
>> U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN
QUICK TO BLAME THE CORRUPTION
AND MISMANAGEMENT FOR THE
COUNTRY'S ECONOMIC TROUBLES.
>> WORKERS ARE NOT GETTING PAID.
STRIKES ARE A DAILY OCCURRENCE.
AND THE REALITY IS PLUMMETING.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT A STAG A
DATING STAGGERING 25%.
>> THEY SUGGEST THAT THE ANGER
IS NOT ONLY ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
CONCERNS.
>> THE RECENT PROTESTS INCLUDING
THE NATIONWIDE BUS AND TRUCK
DRIVER STRIKES ARE DESIGNED TO
SAY THAT POLITICS AND ECONOMICS
ARE LINKED IN THE PUBLIC.
AND THOSE WHO WANT A BETTER LOTS
ALSO WANT A BETTER GOVERNMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DECISION TO
PULL OUT OF THE DEAL IS GIVING
THE REGIME AMMUNITION TO TAKE A
HARD LINE WITH FRENCH ENERGY
COMPANY TOTAL.
IT HAS 60 DAYS TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO SECURE AN
EXEMPTION FROM AMERICAN
SANCTIONS PRAYED OTHERWISE
IRAN'S OIL MINISTER IS
THREATENING TO GIVE CONTROL TO
THE LARGEST GAS FIELD TO A
CHINESE STATE OWNED COMPANY.
>> THIS IS A TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PUTTING THE
FINANCIAL SQUEEZE ON TEHRAN AND
TRYING TO WIN OVER ITS PEOPLE.
>> U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE SAID THAT
THE IRANIAN PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
THE YOUNGER POPULATION ARE EAGER